gamers and superhero fans rejoice
marvel's avengers has finally arrived
and you've come to the right place if
you can't wait to leap into battle
this is everything you need to know
about marvel's avengers
as with most modern aaa titles marvel's
avengers has had a long and complex
development cycle
and this release window has undoubtedly
felt the effects of it
while originally slated for a may 15
2020 release
crystal dynamics took to its website in
january 2020
to provide an update that surely took
fans by surprise
the post which shared the development's
team's desire to deliver an original
story driven campaign
engaging co-op and compelling content
for years to come
also announced that the title would
instead be released on september 4th
2020. there were a number of video games
television shows and movies were delayed
in early 2020
due to the coronavirus pandemic like the
marvel cinematic universe's black widow
film
it seems as though this was not the case
for crystal dynamics new game
instead in its update crystal dynamics
wrote that the delay was required in
order to focus on fine-tuning
and polishing the game to high standards
our fans expect and deserve
crystal dynamics hasn't been shy about
showing off marvel's avengers ever since
the avengers project announcement
trailer
dropped way back in 2017. in the teaser
list of teasers the trailer gave viewers
their first look at
well not all that much save for a few
shots suggestive of everybody's favorite
superheroes
including images like bruce banners
broken glasses in front of a hulk smash
door
and iron man's flickering palm repulsor
the genuine article which finally showed
off the avengers didn't crop up until e3
2019. thor what's your status there are
humans trapped
and lots of small angry men with guns
is that a joke did door make a joke
blending a little bit of the game's
story with a dash of gameplay
some ominous foreshadowing and a hefty
helping of patented banner stark
bickering
the first full-length trailer held fans
over until the next big reveal
october 2019 saw a new trailer featuring
none other than kamala khan
aka ms marvel it also introduced
advanced idea mechanics or aim
a villainous anti-avengers organization
that would get its very own
trailer come august 2020 by far the most
interesting trailer dropped in june
2020.
in it viewers were treated to a deeper
look at miss marvel's storyline
and how it intersects with one of the
game's big bads modok
otherwise known as a mental organism
designed only for killing
thankfully for gamers who have yet to
pick a side in the console war
marvel's avengers won't force you to
choose between microsoft's xbox series x
and playstation 5. and sure while the
game will be available on the ps4 and
xbox one
gamers who go next gen will be able to
upgrade their games for free
what exactly does that mean well
according to crystal dynamics chief
technology officer gary snethen
the ps5's gpu will allow for a slew of
graphical and gameplay improvements
including increased texture resolution
enhanced ambient occlusion
and improved frame rate specifically 60
fps with dynamic 4k resolution
worried about starting on your xbox one
upgrading to the series x and losing all
of that vital progress
don't be crystal dynamics has confirmed
that the game will allow you to transfer
saves across console generations
in a square enix press release crystal
dynamics explains quote
those moving their saves to next gen
will transfer their player profiles and
progression
so they can pick up right where they
left off marvel's avengers will also be
available on pc and google stadia
so here we are avengers assemble
who are you people again
crystal dynamics taps some of the
biggest talent in the video game
industry to step into your favorite hero
super suits and marvel's avengers
playing genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist tony stark aka iron man
is nolan north a longtime voice actor
who boasts hundreds of television
and video game credits ranging from
saints row 4 to the uncharted series
fellow uncharted actor troy baker
another super famous video game veteran
metaphorically done to green guy's
tatted shorts as bruce banner the hulk
like north baker's voice has graced
countless titles including the last of
us
in which he portrayed joel and today
okajima's death stranding
gears of war 4's laura bailey yet
another video game voice acting
superstar
plays super spy turned avenger natasha
romanov
aka black widow steve rogers captain
america is played by resident evil 3
actor jeff shine
while thor's irl counterpart is none
other than laura bailey's hubby
and talent behind marvel spider-man
villain kingpin travis willingham
rounding out the main cast is sandra sad
a newcomer to video game voice acting
who takes on the role of ms marvel
kamala khan
the very first substantial trailer for
marvel's avengers offered gamers a
glimpse of the fast-paced hero
based combat that would make up the
majority of the title's gameplay
each avenger boasted their own set of
killer moves and action was fast
fluid and frenetic then came june 2020's
war table extended gameplay reveal
and everything changed in the nearly 26
minute video
the folks at crystal dynamics showcase a
broad range of attack styles which
include
melee ranged aerial and ground-based
combat skills
players can also upgrade skill trees
using skill points gained through
experience which allows players to mix
and match advanced moves and unique
combat styles for each avenger to top it
all off there's also gear and perks
which both affect your team's stats
some even boast nifty status effects
like shrink which literally transforms
enemies into diminutive versions of
themselves
considering that marvel's avengers is a
live service game
meaning it will be constantly updated
the devs at crystal dynamics will surely
add new gameplay elements to keep
players invested in its gameplay loop
as time goes on marvel's avengers
doesn't adapt any particular story from
the mcu films or its comic book
counterparts
instead it tells a brand new story
centering around a disastrous event
dubbed a day along with the dissolution
of the avengers team
and its reassembly the kid is inhuman
we did this and she needs your help a
day was meant to be a celebration of the
avengers as they unveiled their new san
francisco headquarters
but things take a turn for the deadly
when taskmaster and his goons attack
it turns out that this assault was a
distraction meant to allow the bad guys
to rig the avengers helicarrier
to explode by overloading its
experimental terror gym reactor
not only does the ensuing explosion
seemingly kill captain america
but it also makes a mess of san
francisco and releases a terrorist miss
that transforms regular citizens of san
fran
into inhumans with special abilities
following the devastation of a day and
the rise of aim
an organization that believes science is
responsible for maintaining order not
superheroes
the avengers go their separate ways it's
up to kamala khan whose ability to
ambiguon resulted from her exposure to
the terrigen mist to reunite the
superhero team and take the fight back
to aim
modok and all the rest of the big bads
kicking bad guy booty is fun but kicking
bad guy booty in style is even better
which is why the cosmetic customization
options at marvel's avengers are so
nifty
feel like letting thor dress down for
the day no problem stick him in his
donald blake outfit
is hulk in the mood for a little morally
ambiguous vegas pizzazz throw his joe
fix it skin on and get to smashing
just like in many other modern video
games these skins are unlocked to both
through mission chains and the game's
online marketplace
while each hero has their own sort of
battle pass in the form of hero
challenge cards
40 tier reward trees that could unlock
all sorts of spiffy stuff by completing
various challenges
players can also buy credits using real
world money yes ladies and gentlemen for
better or for worse marvel's avengers
will have micro transactions for skins
emotes nameplates and takedowns which
are basically flashy moves that show off
your favorite avengers style
marvel's avengers will allow players to
dish out real dough to score in-game
skins emotes and the like and while
microtransactions have become pretty
normal and stigmatized in gaming
crystal dynamics is doing something a
lot less common when it comes to dlc
they're giving it to players for free
every new superhero
and every new region will be delivered
at no additional cost
as the persistent world of marvel's
avengers grows the folks behind the
scenes will be distributing free dlc
characters
like the upcoming hawkeye along with
free regions in other words co-op squad
mates on a budget will never have to
suffer from hero
mv while they watch their bff's bash
skulls as a favorite paid dlc only
avenger
that said there is one caveat and it's
kind of a stinker at least for xbox and
pc gamers in early august 2020
crystal dynamics announced that
spider-man will be joining marvel's
avengers
exclusively on playstation 4 and
playstation 5. the drawings still out on
whether xbox and pc players will get
their own exclusive characters
while the main cast of marvel's avengers
is sure to keep players pleased for now
crystal dynamics aims to give gamers an
even broader roster of heroes to choose
from
ames being the key word here while the
devs teased clint barton aka hawkeye as
a dlc character back in july 2020
the team confirmed the addition of
another hawkeye on september 1st 2020.
enter kate bishop barton's young protege
and fellow archer extraordinaire
i believe some of you know kate bishop
oh we've met
bishop was first introduced during
marvel's avengers launch week war table
which also showcased operations
post-campaign single-player dlc
packs that will boast new heroes
villains regions
and gear bishop's operation is called
taking aim while barton's operation is
dubbed future imperfect
a playstation blog post describes them
as a double feature
according to the post bishop is voiced
by emmy award winning writer and fan
favorite video game voice actress
ashley birch of horizon zero dawn fame
barton on the other hand will be
portrayed by grey's anatomy actor
giacomo giannatti
well crystal dynamics also announced
spider-man as a ps4
and ps5 exclusive hero the websingers
operation
if he has one has yet to get a formal
reveal
one of marvel's avengers first big
selling points was its co-op gameplay
which would allow players to team up
with three of their pals to pummel the
living daylights out of marvel's most
wanted
although the titles online multiplayer
mechanics were mentioned in press
releases and trailers
it wouldn't be until june 2020's war
table that prospective players would get
a peek at marvel's avengers 4-player
co-op mode
its name warzones existing outside of
the single-player campaign
war zones allows up to four players to
select their favorite avenger
customized gear and all and team up to
reign held down on the aim threat
as described in the june war table video
war zones range in both objective and
size
while some take place in large
environments designed for exploration
and team traversal
others take place in smaller more
cramped and more chaotic environments
as the war table video points out
variety is the name of the game when it
comes to war zones their objective based
challenges differ from mission to
mission
and so do their rewards marvel's
avengers has been marketed as a
persistent four-player co-op action game
but that's not a sale to be lacking in
the single player department
on the contrary its solo campaign will
allow players to embody specific
avengers as they each tackle missions
respective to their character
these solo experiences are called hero
missions and according to june's war
table
they give players a chance to dive
deeper into each hero's story
simultaneously these missions showcase
the game's diverse hero design
a fancy way of saying that each mission
is tailored specifically to its
respective heroes abilities
you should know i'm not in the best of
moves
june's wartable shows off one of these
experiences using the thor focus hero
mission once an avenger as an example
in the mission thor is tasked with
eliminating the aim robots that are
attempting to burrow into the hull of
the chimera heller carrier
action-packed task-based and
story-driven hero missions allow gamers
new to the avengers to learn about their
heroes
and let longtime fans watch familiar
stories and fold in new ways
in movies tv shows and video games the
bad guys are just as important as the
good guys
after all what's the point of a
superhero squad without villains to
challenge them
it turns out that there will be plenty
of those challenges in marvel's avengers
at least if the game's roster of
confirmed baddies has anything to say
about it revealed in the aptly named
modog threat trailer
the grotesque modak also known as george
tarot in
also appears to be pulling the strings
behind ames anti-inhuman propaganda
a founding member of the organization
charlton believes that he could improve
the world through science
and fortunately he is transformed
following the events of ade
after which he begins to push the agenda
that superheroes are beyond the public's
control
this allows him to turn the public and
aims technologies against the avengers
but modoc isn't the only big bad butting
heads with us mightiest
a team led by taskmaster the
photoreflexic dude in the skull mask
from the first trailer
is apparently responsible for blowing up
the avengers helicarrier on aiday
and the big green abomination aka emil
blansky
will be throwing down with the hulk at a
certain point in the game
though marvel's avengers 59.99 standard
and digital editions are complete
packages in their own right
gamers willing to dish out big doa in
for equally big bonuses
at 79.99 the deluxe edition of marvel's
avengers includes a base game
plus a handful of cool goodies namely
the exclusive obsidian outfit pack
so you can deck your avengers out in
sleek sci-fi style
it also comes with a handful of obsidian
themed nameplates along with 72-hour
early access for players who pre-ordered
this
package deluxe is cool and all but real
fans may want to get a little more bang
for their buck
yes mightiest edition of marvel's
avengers boasts a beefy price tag of
199.99
and while that's no chump change what
you'll get for that price at the
proverbial treasure trove of avengers
swag
as explained by its listing in the
square enix store it contains marvel's
avengers deluxe edition
exclusive steel book black widow belt
buckle iron man's prototype armor
blueprints
bionia keychain six inch hulk bobble
head
honorary avenger pin and a 5x7 avengers
day group photo
marvel's avengers doesn't start with a
bang but rather a fangirly squeal as
players meet their ever cheerful kamala
khan the young avengers superfan
instantly emerges at the heart of the
game as she spends the opening moments
of a day trading comics with a fellow
attendee
and sampling all of the high-tech games
the event has to offer
sandra saad's performance as a
hopelessly optimistic khan might steal
the show
but the entire cast of marvel's avengers
really hits their marks
mostly performances range from troy
baker's subdued against type take on
bruce banner to thomas willingham's oh
so close to cringy thorham fest
lucky for you i am mighty graphically
the game is what you'd expect from a
2020
aaa title environment and action set
pieces are rich if a bit repetitive
and animations are fluid for the most
part thankfully having been further
polished by crystal dynamics artists
the digital avengers themselves look far
less uncanny than they did
back when they were revealed the
gameplay while buttermashy at times is
both frantic
and fluid with black widow's early
scuffle with taskmaster being a
highlight
the fight which combines fast-paced
combo based combat with cinematic quick
time events
evokes the best melee moments from
insomniac spider-man
marvel's avengers feels like one of
those more than the sum of its parts
type deal
it does character moments combat and
cinematic bombast pretty dang well
culminating in a big sometimes messy
always blustery superhero game
with a long lifespan thanks to the
promise of free future content
lupro received a review code from the
publisher we played marvel's avengers on
a playstation 4 pro
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies
tv shows and games are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you